before we wrap and this has been an
extended discussion and I appreciate it
it's good that we've had this platform
to talk about a lot of the things
happening the NFL Jameis Winston clearly
available now he told you in August that
he still harbors baseball dreams and
I've been mentioning that thinking about
that all week because after making 45
million over the first five years of his
NFL career if no one is gonna give him a
chance to compete to be a starter if
he's gonna be a guy who holds a
clipboard does he at least entertain the
possibility of the Tim Tebow route jump
on the bus get on a single a team and
try to play baseball why not now if
you're ever gonna do it now's the time
to do it and you're walking away from
what five six million a year as a backup
something you don't want to do you want
to play do you think that this is the
time for Jameis Winston to indulge his
desire to play baseball Mike I think
that before I would do that if I were
him and I think it's an interesting
question I have no idea what his mental
frame of mind right now is it wouldn't
shock me though because before he I'll
never forget this I talked to him coming
out of the combine in 2015 and he told
me at the time that he would love to be
able in the offseason to spend a couple
of months being a closer for somebody
and you know we're pitching somewhere he
throws 95 he might be the kind of guy
with his sort of mental frame of mind
he's not an overly emotional guy he
might be the kind of guy who you could
say you know we'd let him be a closer
but I think of that and then I think of
where he is right now and he probably
really wants to show people that the
Bucks should have believed in me this
was a year one and and with aryans and
and I'm gonna be really good but I think
the biggest issue that I have right now
my biggest issue is I would need
somebody if I were Jameis Winston to
look at him and say you know what I
even you and I can make you better and I
know that everybody in Pittsburgh has
told me don't be an idiot
they're never gonna take Jameis Winston
Ben's the quarterback here for the next
couple of years if I was Mike Tomlin I
would think very seriously about trying
to have that conversation just to see if
there he can now why you know why can't
Mike Tomlin face time right now with
Jameis Winston have a heart-to-heart
talk with him private nobody ever knows
it happens what why can't he do that
just to see where his head is at of
course it it'd be better if he could do
it face to face but he can so why can't
he face time right now with Jameis
Winston and just talk to him about where
he is does he still want to be a great
quarterback would you sit for a year or
two if I gave you every chance to be
next in Pittsburgh and I don't disagree
with that conceptually but I'll tell you
what if I'm Jameis Winston I'm
interested in taking over Teddy
Bridgewater's spot as number two behind
Drew Brees look at what it did for
Bridgewater Brees is only there one more
year maybe Brees gets injured at some
point if not if Taysom Hill stays though
I'm oh I don't it yeah but but they need
they need a veteran who can run the
standard offense because Hills gonna
need his own offense they need somebody
who's ready to play and I think it would
be and who knows maybe Ben
Roethlisberger suffers another
season-ending injury in week two like
last year I just think Drew Brees is
gonna be more welcoming to Jameis then
Ben Roethlisberger would be I think
Ben's gonna be a little more territorial
about this especially as he tries to
re-establish himself after last season I
think that is the the potential pressure
point there
I don't think Ben wants someone that
would threaten him implicitly I think
Brees is fine with it Brees is getting
his money he's there one more year and
that's that and Winston if he gets to
play in a couple of games maybe kind of
cleanses the palate and get somebody to
say alright you know what
with the right coach he's not going to
have a bunch of interceptions he's not
going to average almost two per game he
can be taught he can learn I think to me
that's
best opportunity if he wants to lay the
foundation to be a starter again in the
future
yeah I guess so Mike but I'm not sure
that Ben Roethlisberger should have that
that power inside the Steelers
you shouldn't how can you be sure that
Ben Roethlisberger of--this burgers
playing 15 games this year
if I gave you an over-under right now if
Vegas didn't over-under starts by Ben
Roethlisberger this year what would it
be eight and a half twelve right yeah so
what I know you know I think his body
could be it could be it could go ahead
of court why should Ben Roethlisberger
be all pissy if they bring in Jameis
Winston really think about it yeah I
don't say be or if they bring in Andy
Dalton if they bring in a guy who's been
an established starter we can't rely on
you Ben
we can't we want you to be our
quarterback if you're healthy for the
next three years wonderful then we have
misjudged and overpaid a backup guy and
a potential heir but hey if we have to
do that great you know and I don't look
I I think you're right and he had mike
vick there as a backup at one point and
my god if he can survive mike vick being
a backup in pittsburgh he can survive
Jameis Winston or Andy Dalton I just
think that from the standpoint of the
overall likelihood of Jameis Winston
parlaying this year into starting again
next year I'd be more inclined to go
with Sean Payton and fill that spot the
teddy bridgewater had for the last
couple of years because it worked
21 million per year for Bridgewater
after playing six games since the end of
the 2015 season
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports